Hôm nay, 5 tháng 12 năm, hành hành hình khu chăm 1 năm, mang New South Wales,
ở trên lìa cho biết sẽ giá sốt lại lực kìm số xún,
có nghiệp quy trình phản đứng của lượng kể sát.
Được thái này, được lưu ra sau vụ xa xún hàng là tẹ bãi bình bôn đi của Sydney
và tôi qua khiến vụ xa uỡ tịt mạng, bao gồm một trong hành hình phạm của vụ xa xún.
Thưa kể sát, vụ xa xún sẽ ra trong khoảng mùi phút,
nhằm vào lễ hội hành khá của cộng bồng xa thái tẹ bãi bình bôn đi.
Há tẹ xún được xo diện là chá và con trải,
nguy trà năm 2019, tẹ hình trường cho khi con trải hành tư tuổi bị thương nằm và đuí sị tẹ bình biệt.
Hãy sát chương cộng bố xin tình các đi phạc,
cũng như chưa xa diện cuối tình, nhưng cho biết,
nguy trà đá sẽ hiểu về phép xử dụng xún tự năng hành hình khu chăm mấy lâm và có tới xong khổ xún,
được có phép hưởng pháp, hơn đúng không biết người vẫn đa đuí sị tẹ bình biệt.
Chúng đòo có hai kể sát bị thương nằm,
các nạn nhân có độ tùi tùi tùi tùi mười đến tá miệng.
Một tình công tệ 1 đi đến xấu vụ bảo lực xun đạn nhưng chó mức trong gần bà mi năm qua.
Kể sát chừng băng niềm xa,
wale, sứ bố vụ xa xún là một hành vi khu bố theo lực pháp biệt phương.
Ở chứ đi ra vụ nước xe là một trong những cuối xa ăn toàn nhất thế giới,
mới các vụ xa xún hàng và rất hiểm khi xe ra.